your current citizen lab no culpa
directamente al estado español pero si
establece un vínculo entre el espionaje
y los gobiernos de españa como ha podido
ser usada esa información en el contexto
político catalán
si pensamos que es la
digamos investigación de espionaje mayor
que ha habido en 20 de los países de la
unión europea se han investigado a 65
políticos 63 son políticos catalanes y 2
son políticos vascos 65 nunca antes
había pasado esto obviamente españa es
una democracia pero esto demuestra que
no es una democracia plena como lo puede
ser francia o gran bretaña o alemania y
eso redundaría en esta situación
recordemos que los informes que ha
habido por ejemplo sobre españa
alrededor de esos temas indican que
justamente donde hay un problema es en
las relaciones entre el poder judicial y
el poder
ejecutivo se han investigado entre estos
entre las personas a cuatro presidentes
del gobierno de cataluña ya dos
presidentes del parlamento de cataluña
es una situación inaudita no se sabe
nada pero está claro que el programa
pegasso sólo está en manos de gobiernos
si hablando de relaciones qué
consecuencias políticas podría tener
esta información en la relación entre el
gobierno regional de cataluña y el
gobierno central de españa
pues de momento se han cortado las
relaciones podríamos se ha suspendido
sería la palabra más cauta se han
suspendido las relaciones entre el
gobierno autonómico de cataluña y el
gobierno central de españa y el gobierno
de pedro sánchez asegura que en españa
no se espía si no es al amparo de la ley
asumiendo que este espionaje pueda tener
una base legal podría tener
consecuencias políticas y es sólo el
actual gobierno de pedro sánchez quien
debe dar explicaciones o también nos
debemos retrotraer hasta el gobierno de
mariano rajoy
pues bien de hecho son los dos gobiernos
lo sorprendente es de que es el gobierno
de mariano rajoy pues parecería que
estaba involucrado en esta situación
pero
en el caso de el gobierno de pedro
sánchez parecería que no debería estar
perdíamos por constante con la relación
con los partidos
independentistas incluso en el apoyo
parlamentario que tiene sí y teniendo en
cuenta esta continuidad del espionaje en
los gobiernos como puede saberse si ha
obtenido más parte de culpa al gobierno
de rajoy o como puede
no sé cómo podemos saber si el cine y ha
actuado el cine y para que lo sepa
nuestros televidentes desde el centro
nacional de inteligencia español ha
actuado por su propia parte a parte de
lo que pueda haber dicho los gobiernos
españoles si su pregunta es clave porque
es una de las cuestiones a dilucidar si
el centro nacional de inteligencia que
son servicios de gente ha tuvo ado sin
al menos el conocimiento del ministerio
interior sería grave ya es grave que se
haya de investigar ya sea en espía 265
políticos de hasta 5 partidos políticos
distintos 5 catalanes y 11 vasco esto ya
en sí es grave pero más grave sería
incluso que esto se hubiera hecho a
espaldas incluso de los propios
políticos